اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم مشاهدينا هذه
الخامسه ونبدا بالعناوين
سكي في بخموت لدعم دفاعاتها وحرب تصريحات
بين موسكو ولندن حول امداد كييف بقذاء
فيورانيوم
السلطات الالمانيه تقود حمله مداهمات
وتشتبك مع عناصر مرتبطه بجماعه الرايخ
اليمنيه
بعد اردوغان كليتشار جلو يقدم اوراق
الترشحه للانتخابات وحزب الشعوب الكرديه
ينسحبوا من المنافسه
تظاهرات كبيره في فرنسا بعد رفض الرئيس
ماكرون التراجع عن قانون سن التقاعد
الجدلي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا الخامس اذا من حرب
التصريحات بين موسكو ولندن حول خطط
الاخيره بتزويد كيب بقذائف اليورانيوم
المنظم وفي الوقت الذي تهم فيه الرئيس
بوتين الغرب بنشر اسلحه باوكرانيا تحمل
مكون نووي دفعت بريطانيا عن امتداداتها
العسكريه الكلاب قالت ان هذه الذخيره لا
علاقه لها بالاسلحه النوويه
طبعا مشاهدينا لم تتوقف التصريحات الروسيه
المندده بهذه الصفقه المحتمله وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
قرار بريطانيا بتزويد اوكرانيا بقذائف من
اليورانيوم يصعد من مستويات جديده وايضا
خطيره سيؤدي ايضا الى عواقب وخيمه على
علاقات موسكو ولندن
قبل ذلك كان وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
كليفر قد اكد ان تزويدك بهذه القذائف
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم ليس تصعيدا نوويا
متهما موسكو بانها هي من تسعى للتصعيد
النووي
شبح تطور الصراع في اوكرانيا لحرب النوويه
عاد للواجهه من جديد موسكو توعدت لندن
بنهايه سيئه اذا نفذت تعهد بارسال قذائف
مصنوعه من اليورانيوم المخضب الى كييف
التعهد البريطاني جلب الردود افعال
الروسيه لو تحققت فربما تنقل الصراع في
اوكرانيا الى مرحله مخيفه الرئيس الروسي
حذر من ان بلاده ستضطر الى الرد وتعمل غرب
بنشر اسلحه تحمل مكونا نوويا التحذير
الروسي شمل واشنطن رغم نفي البنتاجون اي
دور لبلاده في هذا الشان
واضح ان الغرب قرر محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا ليس فقط بالكلام بل بالافعال اذا
حصل هذا الشيء فستجد روسيا نفسها مجبره
على الرد بما يتناسب مع تزويد الغرب لا
وكرانيا باسلحه نوويه
بريطانيا من جهتها بدات غير قلقه من سيل
الوعيد الروسي بل علقت بسخريه على ما صدر
عن الكرملين ووصفته بالتضليل المقصود
واقرت الدفاع البريطانيه ان جيشها يستخدم
اليورانيوم المخطب في قذائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود هذه النوعيه من القذائف
خطيره على البيئه حيث قالت الامم المتحده
انها قد تشكل مصدر قلق بيئي في اوكرانيا
لما قد تسببه من امراض بما في ذلك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان حنان المصري العربيه
والمزيد معنى من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعم اهلا بك وايضا ينضم الينا من
لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو وابدا معك
قراءتك وقراءه المتابعين لهذه التصريحات
البريطانيه ما وراء هذا النوع من عدم
الاكتراث اذا ما صح التعبير والوصف
للتهديدات الروسيه من قبل بريطانيا على
ماذا تعول بريطانيا بهذا الاطار
حقيقه ان يعني ارسال ذخيره واسلحه الى
اوكرانيا ليس بالجديد لكن المثير وهو ان
بعض القذائس بها مكون وهو يورانيوم مستنفذ
هذا هذا المنتج الذي يعني
يتم صنعه على خلفيه التخصيب اليورانيوم
للوقود والاسلحه النوويه وتقول وزاره
الدفاع في بيان على غير عادتها ردا على
روسيا بان بانها تحاول تضليل المعلومات
عمدا قالت بان الجيوش معروفه بانها تستخدم
هذا المنتج
لليورانم المنظم وبما فيها الجيش الروسي
ولا علاقه لهذا المكون
بالاسلحه النوويه او استخدامه في اي اطار
نووي هذا بالاضافه الى ان حتى
قاده جيوش سابقين في جيش البريطاني يعني
قالوا بان التصريحات كانت يعني مضحكه
ومثيره
وكانت مقصوده بالتحديد الى الشعب الروسي
وايضا الى الرئيس الصيني الذي الذي زار
موسكو وبالتالي هذه معلومات مظلمه يعني
يجب التوقف عنها لكن نفى ايضا في نفس
الوقت وزير الخارجيه
بان يكون هناك تصعيد نووي في الحرب
الاوكرانيه ولكن هناك فقط
عسكريه الروسيه تصب باطار اخر تقول بانه
الاسوء سيكون قادم بحال تم تسليم الاسلحه
اعود اليك ولكن اسمح لي ان افهم المخاوف
الروسيه اذا بالفعل كانت التصريحات
البريطانيه
واقعيه فيما يتعلق بامكان ان روسيا تستخدم
مثل هذه الاسلحه وانه هذا الموضوع
في نوع من التضليل كاتيا ما الذي يخيف
روسيا من هذه الاسلحه
اعتبرت ان تسليم اي نوع من السلاح من قبل
الغرب ولندن ايضا لاوكرانيا هو بمثابه
مشاركه بهذه الحرب مع روسيا هي تعتبر ان
الغرب يحاول اطاله مدى هذا الحرب في على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وان الغرب لا يكتثر لا
يكترث بالشعب الاوكراني هو يريد ان يقاتل
حتى اخر اوكرانيا هناك طبعا التصريحات
تتوالى حتى على لسان حليفه روسيا
بيلاروسيا الان منذ قليل كان قد تحدث
الرئيس بيلاروسي ان
هذا هذه الخطوه من قبل لندن ستكون كارثيه
على العالم باسره اذا اخططها طبعا هو تحدث
ان الرد سيكون كارثي لكل العالم وسيكون
درسا لكل العالم وان موسكو في حال تسلمت
اوكرانيا هذه القذائف وقامت باستخدامها
ستقوم ايضا هي بتسليم بيلاروسيا بقذائف من
هذا النوع ايضا قذائف نوويه اليوم ايضا
بالنسبه لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه اعتبر ان
هذه الخطوه هي تصعيديه وان هذه الخطوه هي
خطوه جديده نحو نحو صدام مباشر مع الغرب
هو ايضا اكد على ان الغرب
لاوكرانيا وهذا سينعكس ايضا على المواطنين
الاوكرانيين من حيث طبعا سلامه صحتها وعلى
التربه التي طبعا كما تعلمين ان اوكرانيا
هي اكبر مزود في العالم بالقمح والتي
ستصبح غير صالحه في حال استخدام هذه
القنابل وهنا انتقل الى مصطفى هل بالفعل
غرب غير مفترس يبدو انه روسيا تعتبر انه
هذا تصعيد بالنسبه لها التصريحات
البريطانيه يبدو انها غير مقنعه
ويبدو بالمقابل انه بريطانيا مصره على
تسليم الاسلحه متى
حقيقه يعني الغرب او النيتو يعني يعني
هناك اجماع بان لا احد يريد يعني اصطدام
مباشر غربي مع القوات الروسيه هذا واضح
للغايه وهذا خط احمر بالنسبه لجميع الدول
الغربيه بالاضافه الى ان منذ اعلان
بريطانيا تزويد عن نيتها تزويد اوكرانيا
باربع عشره دبابه كانت هناك 100 بان يتم
يعني ارسالها بنهايه هذا الشهر لكن لا
نعرف حقيقه سيتم ارسالها بنهايه الشهر او
ربما في بدايه الشهر المقبل بالطبع سيكون
تصريح رسمي لوزاره الدفاع عندما يتم تسليم
هذه
المجموعه من الدبابات الى القوات الروسيه
يجب التذكير بان منذ قبل حتى قبل بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت بريطانيا يعني
تدرب الجيش الاوكراني قدم قدم التسهيلات
كبيره هناك ما يقل عن ملياري و 300 مليون
جنيه استرليني تم يعني انفاق انفاقها على
الجيش الاوكراني بارسال معدات عسكريه
بالتدريب بالاضافه الى المساعدات
الاقتصاديه لمساعده الشعب الاوكراني وهذا
هو ما اكد عليه رئيس الوزراء
قال بان حجم المساعده العسكريه لن تقل عن
مليارين وثلاث مئه جنيه استرليني التي تم
انفاقها العام الماضي وبالتالي هناك
امكانيه ان يتم يعني زياده هذا الدعم
العسكري في الوقت القريب مصطفى كوننا
نتحدث عن بريطانيا نتابع العواجل الان
البرلمان البريطاني سيفتح استجواب ضد
الرئيس البريطاني السابق باريس جونسون لا
اعلم ان كان لديك معلومات عن خلفيه هذا
الاستجواب او تريد ان نكمل فيما يتعلق
المشاده بالتصريحات اذا مصحه التعبير ما
بين موسكو وبريطانيا
موضوع الساعه في السياسه البريطانيه اليوم
وهو مثول بوريس جونسون للرد على استفسارات
يعني تتعلق بفضائح الحفلات غير القانونيه
خلال فتره الاغلاق كان هناك تم نشر يعني
موجز
للتحقيق الذي الذي تم الاشراف عليه هو
نشرت اجزاء منه من قبل هذه اللجنه الخاصه
للامتيازات التي تنظر فيما اذا ظلل بوريس
جونسون مجلس العموم وان كان ان ظلل عمدا
فهذا سيؤدي الى فرض بعض العقوبات على برج
جونسون تتمثل ما بين تقديم اعتذار الى
ابعاده من مجلس العموم لفتره وان كانت هذه
المده تتجاوز ربما عشره ايام او اسبوعين
ربما سيتم طرده من مجلس العموم وسيتم عقد
يعني انتخاب نائب جديد عن الدائره التي
يمثلها وبالتالي الكل الانظار تنصب على
هذا الاستجواب الماسونيه ربما سيمتد لاكثر
من اربع ساعات اليوم وسيتم يعني رفع
التوصيات اللجنه بخصوص عقاب برج دونسون ان
تم فعلا التواصل الى نتيجه بانه ظلل وكذب
على البرلمان بشكل
يعني كان يعرف خلفيه انه خرق القانون ولكن
تفادى
ان يعترف بانه ارتكب خطا وخرق القانون
الذي وضع نفسه وبالتالي هذا ما سيتم
التعرف عليه في سنتعرف اكثر
هذه التوصيات للتصويت على البرلمان ونتابع
معك طبعا في نشراتنا القادمه من لندن
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زورو شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المعلومات اشكر ايضا مراسله
العربيه من موسكو كاتيا طعمه
اليورانيوم المنظم هو اليورانيوم المستنفذ
وهو معدن كثيف ناتج عن تخصيب اليورانيوم
الطبيعي للوقود النووي او الاستعماله في
الاسلحه
يتسم اليورانيوم المنظم بانه مشع بدرجه
معتدله في شكله الصلب لكنه ماده ثقيله جدا
واكثر كثافه بواحد فصل سبعه من عشره مره
من الرصاص يستخدم لتقويه القذائف حتى
تتمكن من اختراق الدروع والصلب فعندما
يضرب سلاح مصنوع من اليورانيوم المنضب
دبابه مثلا يخترقها ثم ينفجر مطلقا البخار
والغبار السام الى حد ما وفي حين ان جميع
متفرعات اليورانيوم مشعه لكن اليورانيوم
المنظم اقل نشاطا اشعاعيا بنسبه 40% من
اليورانيوم غير المعالج
وفي متابعه لتداعيات زياره الرئيس الصيني
حتى المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
حتى واشنطن على تصحيح سلوكها في القضيه
الاوكرانيه وايضا التوقف عما اسماه بالقاء
اللوم على بكين المسؤول الصيني اكد ان
بكين ستواصل دورها لايجاد حل سياسي للازمه
في اوكرانيا نتابع
نحث الولايات المتحده على دراسه دورها في
القضيه الاوكرانيه وتصحيح سلوكها الخاطئ
المتمثل في صب الزيت على النار والتوقف عن
القاء اللوم على الصين سنواصل الوقوف بحزم
الى جانب السلام والحوار والصواب التاريخي
والعمل بشكل بناء مع المجتمع الدولي
لمواصله دورنا في تعزيز حل سياسي للقضيه
الاوكرانيه
اما في موسكو ورغم تاكيد بكين انها ستواصل
الجهود لتسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا المتحدث
باسم الكرملين ديمتري بسكوب قال ان بوتين
ونظيره الصيني لم يناقشا خطه بكين للسلام
في اوكرانيا خلال المحادثات اضاف ان
التغطيه التي وصفها بغير الوديه في الغرب
لزياره الرئيس الصيني شي جينبنج الى روسيا
كانت متوقعه واوضح ايضا ان الكرملين لا
يولي اهتمام لرد فعل الغرب على زيارته الى
روسيا وانما لنتائجها
رئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوس مورويكو
يقال انه يعتبر المحور الروسي الصيني خطير
طبعا في اعقاب المحادثات الاخيره التي
اجراها الرئيس الصيني مع بوتين في
الكرملين نتابع ايضا
زياره رئيس الصيني لموسكو زادت من حده
القلق الحاصل هذا المحور بين الصين وروسيا
خطيره نحاول اقناع الصين بعدم دعم روسيا
في سياستها الدوليه العدوانيه هناك نظام
جيوسي جديد يظهر امام اعيننا واصبح امن
اليابان وبولندا فجاه ظاهره يجب مناقشتها
في وقت واحد فيما يتعلق بالتهديدات التي
تتعرض لها اسيا واوروبا
ننتقل الى الصعيد الميداني وبعد تقارير
بريطانيه حول خطوره الوضع في باخموت حيث
باتت القوات طبعا معرضه للحصار شمالا
وايضا جنوبا زار الرئيس الاوكراني
مواقع عسكريه للجيش بالقرب من بلده بخموت
طبعا الواقعه على خط المواجهه مع القوات
الروسيه في شرق اوكرانيا والتي تعد مسرحا
لاطول المعارك بين كيف وموسكو منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا
وفي هذه الاثناء اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي
الانتهاء من تحديث منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الروسي بنهايه العام الجاري اشار الى ان
القوات الجويه دمرت اكثر من 20 الف منشاه
في اوكرانيا ونفذت اكثر من 140 الف طلعه
جويه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
كوريا الشماليه تحذر من الضغوط عليها
للتخلي عن الاسلحه النوويه وتقول انه
بمثابه اعلان حرب
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكملها من
المانيا حيث اعلنت السلطات تنفيذ مداهمات
على صله بحركه الرايخ طبعا هي تنتمي لاقصى
اليمين قالت وسائل الاعلام المانيه ان هذه
المداهمات تتعلق بالتحقيقات في قضيه خليه
الرايخ حيث تمت في سبع ولايات مراسله
العربيه اشارت الى ان حمله المداهمات
استهدفت خمسه من المشتبه بهم وان شرطيا من
القوات الخاصه اصيب بطلق ناري من عنصر
بالخليه وذلك اثناء عمليه مداهمه للقبض
عليه في احدى الولايات بغرب المانيا
الى فرنسا الان حيث شدد رئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون في مقابله تلفزيونيه قبيل التصعيد
المرتقى من قبل المحتاجين على تمرير قانون
التقاعد غدا شدد على ضروره ان يدخل هذا
القانون حيز التنفيذ هذا العام ماكرون قال
ان قانون اصلاح التقاعد الضروري لانقاذ
النظام باكمله اكد انه لا يمكن قبول
التمرد في الشارع ضد قانون التقاعد وسيتم
العمل على عوده الوضع الى طبيعته في فرنسا
باسرع وقت كما اضاف الرئيس الفرنسي ان
القانون لا يعجبه شخصيا لكنه من اجل
المصلحه العامه
كما اخبرتكم هل تعتقدون ان هذا القانون
يعجبني قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد لا
يعجبني شخصيا ولكنه من اجل المصلحه العامه
واود الاشاره الى انه يجب ان يدخل قانون
التقاعد حيز التنفيذ بحلول نهايه هذا
العام وقانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد ضروري
لانقاذ النظام باكمله في الوقت ذاته لا
يمكن قبول التمرد في الشارع ضد قانون
التقاعد وسنعمل على العوده الى الحياه
الطبيعيه في فرنسا باسرع وقت
يبدو ان الرد جاء سريعا على
تصريحات وانطلبت المديريه العامه للطيران
المدني من شركات الطيران الغاء 30% من
رحلاتها المقرره غدا في مطار باريس وعشرين
بالمئه في المطارات الاخرى للضغط على
الحكومه للتراجع عن قانون التقاعد
المديريه قالت لوكاله فرانسبريس ان منصات
الطيران ستتاثر بالغاء واحده من كل خمس
رحلات تغادر او تصل يوم غد
لكن ما هي الخيارات امام الرئيس ماكرون
لتهدئه موجه هذه الاضرابات وايضا
الاحتجاجات التي تحولت لمواجهات عنيفه مع
الشرطه في الايام الماضيه رغم فشل الاحزاب
المعارضه في حجب الثقه عن حكومه اليزابيث
بورن الا ان هذا لا يعني بان المعركه
الهادفه لاسقاط قانون التقاعد قد انتهت
قررت نقابات العمال والمعارضه تنظيم يوم
احتجاجي جديد غدا طبعا للضغط على ماكرون
ولحثه على سحب القانون المثير للجدل هناك
خياران امام المعارضه احدهما اللجوء الى
المجلس الدستوري طبعا للنظر في شرعيه
وقانونيه القانون او اللجوء الى تنظيم
استفتاء شعبي لحسم هذه القضيه مع ذلك بعض
المتتبعين للسياسه يعتقدون انه في حال
اراد ماكرون العوده الى وسط اللعبه عليه
اي يتخذ بعض القرارات الجريئه كسحب
القانون او تعيين حكومه جديده والا فانه
سيواجه مشاكل كثيره في البرلمان من اجل
تمرير قوانين اخرى قانوني الهجره والعمل
الذين سيطرحان للمناقشه في الايام او
الاشهر القليله المقبله من باريس معنى
زينه عدي مراسله العربيه اهلا بك ان ابدا
باخر ما وصلنا حول الغاء بعض الرحلات هذا
كان متوقع ام انه رد مباشر على ماكرون
هو كان متوقع لان
غدا سيكون يعني يوم حاسم بالمواجهه هو
اليوم التاسع من الاضرابات العامه
والوطنيه سيكون هناك احتجاجات واسعه
وكبيره وفي جميع القطاعات او معظمها سيكون
هناك مظاهر من الاضرابات سواء من طرف
الطلاب وايضا المطارات وايضا حركه النقل
العام وسائل النقل العام هناك الكثير من
المظاهر اريك خلفي الان بدات بعد خطاب
ماكرون حركات واسعه على الارض نحن في جده
على بعد اميان فقط من قصر الاليزيه هناك
متظاهرون يعني احتلوا هذا المطعم في
الجاده في محيط المطعم الشرطه ايضا تطوق
المكان للحفاظ على الامن ايضا في مناطق
اخرى في احياء اخرى من باريس جيشه ايضا
يعني حركات كهذه بالنسبه للمتظاهرين في
معارضتها لقانون رفع سن التقاعد اليوم
مكرون في خطابه اججج الشارع الفرنسي من
جديد كانوا مصرا وحاسما في قراره كما اعلن
على انه يعني سيسير في هذا القانون ويطبق
في نهايه هذا العام
مكروه حاول في كلمته تهدئه الشارع من
الناحيه العمليه حاول شرح
اهميه هذا القانون لكن في الواقع اصراره
عليه
بدا بانه سيكون له تاثير واضح على الشارع
الفرنسي وبالمقابل هذا يدفعنا للتساؤل هو
مصر ولكن
بما انه فشل كما ذكرتي زينه في تهدئه
الشارع ما الخيارات امامه الان
ممكن يتراجع او لا
هذا كل هذا يعني القرار سيكون كلمه الفصل
للشارع الفرنسي بالنسبه للمظاهرات كانت
يعني عارمه اكثر من قبل ربما ستؤثر في
قرار حكومته لكن اعرب اليوم في خطابه بانه
سيمضي به وهو متوقع ان تكون الاحتجاجات
واسعه بالمقابل حاول ان يعطي شرعيه
للمظاهرات التي تقوم على
المنظمه والتي تقوم عبر النقابات لكنه
ايضا ميز بان المظاهرات التي تخرج بشكل
عشوائي والتي تقوم
بالتكسير وتقوم بمظاهر العنف هي غير شرعيه
ولن يعني يسمع لها لكنه مد يده للنقابات
ومد يده للمتظاهرين واعتبر بان لهم احقيه
في قول كلمتهم لكنه اصر ايضا على قراره
واجدد جدد ثقته بحكومته حكومه اليز وقال
بانه يعتبر بان هذا القانون هو شرعي
بالنسبه له ونفى ان عدم شرعيته كما يقول
الشارع الفرنسي اعتبر بان القانون عرض
ونقش في البرلمان الفرنسي ثم صوت عليه
مجلس الشيوخ والان هو في المجلس الدستوري
الذي سيقر به بشكل نهائي لذلك ماكرون
يعتبر بان الخطوات التي يقوم بها هي
دستوريه ويحق استخدام هذا البند وهو قد
يستخدم في السابق وهو مسؤول اليوم على
قراره في اتخاذ هذا البنت
وهو جاهز ويتحمل مسؤوليه تبعات هذه الازمه
كانت معنا من باريس مراسله العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
الى تركيا الان حيث قالت برفين بلدان
الرئيس المشاركه لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
قالت ان الحزب المؤيد للاكراد وحلفائه لن
يدفعوا بمرشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وهي
طبعا مقرره في مايو المقبل في تصريحاتها
لم تذكر بلدان ان كانت تحالف يدعم مرشح
معين من المعارضه طبعا هو كمال
يبدو ان قرار حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي بعدم
الدفع بمرشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه سيمثل مع تبرا انتكاسه طبعا
محتمله لمساعي الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
للفوز بفتره جديده فبالرغم من ان الحزب
الذي يشكل ثالث اكبر كتله برلمانيه ويحظى
بنسبه تاييد تتجاوز العشره بالمئه على
مستوى تركيا بالرغم من انه لم يعلن رسميا
موقفه بشان من سيدعم في الانتخابات بالرغم
من ذلك الا ان قاده الحزب عقدوا محادثات
الاسبوع الماضي مع كمال كليتش الدار اوبلو
الذي قدم اوراق ترشحه اليوم عن المعارضه
في الانتخابات وبينما يامل
في بناء تحالفات مع الاكراد والمحافظين
ليتمكن من حسم المنافسه لصالحه يعد تحالف
حزب العداله والتنميه الذي يتزعم اردوغان
معارض قوي للحركه الكرديه
ولمطالبها بالحقوق الثقافيه وهذا طبعا ما
يزيد من التوقعات بان يندفع الاكراد اكثر
نحو خيار المعارضه يرى مراقبون ان اردوغان
يواجهوا اصعب تحدي انتخابي منذ صعوده الى
السلطه لاول مره فالانتخابات تاتي في ظل
ازمات متتاليه من بينها ارتفاع معدل
التضخم وعدم الرضا بشان تصدى الحكومه
للزلزال المدمر الذي وقع في فبراير الماضي
واودى بحياه 48 الف شخص على الاقل
في لبنان اطلقت قواته الامن القنابل
المسيله للدموع باتجاه عسكريين متقاعدين
بعد محاولات الاقتحام السراير الحكومه ما
ادى لسقوط اصابات بسبب الاختناق بحسب
مراسله العربيه قالت المراسله ان حده
المواجهه تراجعت ولكن الاحتجاجات لا زالت
مستمره كانت جمعيه المودعين اللبنانيين
دعت الى الاعتصام في ساحه رياض الصلح
المقابله للسرايا الحكوميه احتجاجا على
سوء الاوضاع المعيشيه
قال مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل ليس لديها خطه لبناء
مستوطنات جديده في منطقه بالضفه الغربيه
كانت قد اخلتها عام 2005 بموجب قانون فك
الارتباط الذي الغاه الائتلاف الحاكم هذا
الاسبوع حيث اثار هذا القرار ادانات عربيه
ودوليه واسعه
[تصفيق]
الى التوترات الان بين واشنطن وبيونج حيث
قال مسؤول كوري شمالي ان الضغوط لتخلي
بيوم يانغ عن الاسلحه النوويه ترقى الى
مستوى اعلان الحرب جاءت التصريحات هذه
والتي نقلتها وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه الرسميه جاءت ردا على ما
ذكرته المندوبه الامريكيه في الامم
المتحده للنداء بريم فيلد حول مساله نزع
السلاح النووي وبشكل كامل من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
رغم الترقب لاعتقاله متحدث باسم ترامب
يقول انه لم يتم اختاره باي تهم وان
تصريحاته تستند لتقارير اعلاميه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من ازمه
اعتقال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب والتي اثرها قبل ايام ترامبال انه
قد لا يواجه لائحه اتهام في النهايه وذلك
في تحقيق المدعي العام في منهات في دفع
اموال لممثله اباحيه من جانبه اوضح متحدث
باسم ترامب ان الرئيس السابق لم يتم
اختاره رسميا بعد بالتهم الموجهه اليه
وانه كان يستند في مزاعمه الى تقارير
اعلاميه
وفي هذا الاطار قالت ترامب انه يريد ان
يتم تقييد يديه عندما يمثل امام المحكمه
اذا وجهت اليه لائحه اتهام وذلك بحسب
مصادر مقربه منه تحدثت مع صحيفه الجارديان
الصحيفه اضافت انه يبدو ان حرصه المتزايد
على الظهور مقيد اليدين عند مثوله امام
المحكمه هي لدوافع سياسيه تتعلق
بالانتخابات ليبدو في دور البطل وان
محاكمته ظالما ما قد يزيد طبعا من اسهمه
الانتخابيه بحسب الصحيفه الصحيفه نقلت عن
مصادر ان ترامب يرى في امكانيه تقييده
واخذ بصماته وصوره الاشتباه الجنائيه فرصه
لتحويلها الى عرض كبير يخدم مصالحه
السياسيه
هذا ويبدو ان حلقات مسلسل ترامب تتواصل مع
احتماليه اي يواجه الرئيس اتهامات جنائيه
في سابقه هي الاولى في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده تتوالد تكهنات حول ما قد يفعله
انصاره وما هي رده الفعل حاله ادانته فعلا
مؤيد ترامبس
ايا كان بداوا التصعيد بالفعل عبر ارسال
سيل من التهديدات الى المسؤولين السياسيين
عبر الانترنت يخشى بعض الخبراء وقوع حدث
طبعا مماثل لاقتحام الكابيتول في السادس
من يناير 20 21 يذهب اخرون الى ان ترامب
الذي لطالم عاشق الاضواء حتى في احلك
اللحظات سيخطط للاستفاده من هذه اللحظه
لجمع التبرعات لحمله ترشحه خاصه في
نيويورك حيث كان دعم ترامب ضئيلا للغايه
في الانتخابات السابقه
في الولايات المتحده عاصفه قضائيه وسياسيه
بطلها دونالد ترامب قرار محكمه منهاتن قد
يؤدي الى اعتقال ترامب في قضيه جنائيه
بخصوص اموال الصمت التي يزعم انه دفعها
للممثله
علاقتها به الممثله السابقه وفي تغريدات
ساخره على حسابها في تويتر كشفت انها
سترقص في الشارع في حال اودينا ترامب ودخل
السجن تغريده
صارت موجه انتقادات ضدها من قبل محبي
ترامب المشكلات القانونيه للترامب لا
تتوقف عند قضيه
بل يواجه العديد من القضايا عاليه المخاطر
ابرزها التحقيقات في جهوده لتخريب نتائج
انتخابات 2020
والتعامل مع السجلات الرئاسيه المعروفه
بقضيه وثائق مارالاغو
[موسيقى]
اذ ينضم الينا من نيويورك مراسل العربيه
حسين اخر المعلومات لديك ملف كبير
طبعا ميسون تحيه لك اولا من المتوقع ان
تجتمع اليوم هيئه المحلفين الكبرى ومن
المتوقع ان توجه الاتهامات لدونالد ترامب
هذه الهيئه ميسون هي تتالف من 23 عضوا
اثنا عشره فقط هم بحجر يصوتوا على توجيه
الاتهام ليتم توجيه الاتهام ولكن لا شيء
مؤكد حتى هذه اللحظه ولكنه توقعات بانه
يتم ذلك الوجود الامني المكثف ما زال
ملاحظ هنا اذا تحركنا قليلا سنشاهد هذه
الحواجز الحديديه اضافه الى الوجود الامني
هناك حضور اعلامي مكثف ميسون من مختلف
وسائل الاعلام ان كانت امريكيه او عالميه
لتغطيه هذا الحدث اذا اذا بالفعل تم توجيه
الاتهام من الملاحظ اليوم انه لا يوجد
متظاهرون
انصارا او معارضين ترامب البارحه كان عدد
منهم هنا يحملون يافتات
ويهت
اليوم حتى الان لا يوجد هكذا تظاهرات لكن
الحواجز الامنيه موجوده الشرطه متواجده
بكثافه هذه هي المحكمه المحكمه الجنايات
في منهاتا جنوب نيويورك حيث ستجتمع الهيئه
وتصوت على يمكن ان تصوت اليوم على توجيه
الاتهام
يقول
بانه لم يتم اختاره بطبيعه هذه الاتهامات
احنا بنعرف شو هي
طبعا هو الاتهام هو يتعلق بموضوع دفع
اموال
للممثله ستورمي دانيالز ولكن هنا اذا
اردنا ان نوضح مساله دفع الاموال بحد ذاته
هو ليس القضيه هو المشكله بتزوير السجل
سجل اعماله عام 2016 حيث يقول المحققون
بان النيه انذاك كانت اخفاء هذه هذه
العلاقه بين ترامب وبين دانييل عفوا
ستورميداني وهذا وذلك
يعتبر
للقانون الانتخابي نعم او تصوير
عماله متعلقه بالانتخابات هاي هي المشكله
الاساسيه بمعنى اخر
هو هو اولا هو دفع يقولون انك كانت نيته
اخفاء العلاقه لهذا وجه محاميه انذاك
مايكل دفع 130 الف دولار
وانه اخفى هذه المعلومه او انه قال بان
هذه المدفوعات كانت مدفوعات كتعويض قانوني
لمحاميه بينما هم يعتبرون ان هذه
المدفوعات كانت لشراء صمتها ولذلك هم
يقولون انه زور سجل اعمال اعماله وهذا
يعتبرونه انه انتهاك للقانون الانتخابي
معروف وكان مرشحا ان ذلك لخوله الانتخابات
الرئاسيه على هذه القضيه هم يركزون ولكن
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في الحقيقه سمعنا
اراء تقول بانها لن تصوت على توجيها
الاتهام الا اذا كان لديها ادله دامغه لان
القضيه قضيه حساسه هذه قضيه هذه سابقه في
التاريخ الامريكي ان توجه لائحه اتهام
للرئيس سابق لذلك هم بحسب المحللين
والخبراء يقولون بانها هذه الهيئه ما زالت
تجمع الادله ولن تصوت على توجيه الاتهام
الا اذا كان بالفعل لديها ادله دامغه لانه
هناك اتهامات من قبل الجمهوريين لها بانها
تعمل اولا
بضغط من جورج سوروس وهو ملياردير
محسوب على اليسار وهي تعمل بسبب دوافع
سياسيه وليس دوافع قالواليه حسب التطورات
لمعرفه المزيد من نيويورك مراسل العربيه
حسين التوت شكرا جزيلا لك
وهذه عوده مشاهدينا للانتخابات التركيه
والاعلان الاخير من قبل حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي والذي اكد بانه لن يدفع بمرشح
من قبله في هذه الانتخابات معنا من
اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي طه عوده
جلو اهلا بك سيد طه بدايه قراءه في هذه
التصريحات وهذه الخطوه عدم الدفع بمرشح
ماذا يعني
تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذه ميسون
والساده المشاهدين من دون شكنا هذا هناك
خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه ترقب حتى في
اصوات الحكومه وهو في اوساط المعارضه فيما
يتعلق بموقف الاكراد وخاصه الحزب الشعب
الديمقراطي الموالي للاكراد هنا اليوم هو
اعلانه عدم اعلان مرشح هو دعم
لحزب او الطور السداسيه وكما كريستار وهذا
من وجهه نظري يصعب من الامور بالنسبه
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الذي هو يحاول قدر
المستطاع خلال الفتره الحاليه بناء وتاسيس
تحالفات
طه اسمح لي لماذا لم يعلنوا ذلك لماذا لم
يعلنوا
الشخصيه التي سيدعموها وهنا نتحدث عن
يعني هناك كما تابعنا بالامس كان هناك
اجتماعات ما بين كريش والحزب الكردي هنا
واعتقد هناك كانت بعض المفاوضات وخاصه
المتعلقه ببعض القضايا المتعلقه بالاكراد
وهناك لم تظهر الصوره واضحه بشكل خاصه هل
تم الموافقه على هذه الشروط ولكن هناك هدف
يجمع كريستيانو والاكراد وهو لصاحب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان هذا هدف واضح ولكن هناك
بالنسبه للحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الموالي
للاكراد هو بالدرجه الاولى هو يحاول قدر
الامكان يعني اطلاق سراح زعيم المتواجد في
السجن وهناك اطلاق بعض الحريات هذه
الاكراد انا بتصور اعتقد هذه هي نقطه ممكن
ان تكون مقبوله من قبل ولكن هناك عقبه
اخرى متعلقه في وجود هناك حزب الجيد مرار
اللي هي من القوميين التي ترفض التحالف مع
الاكراد هذه هي
من الامور يعني تصاعد بالنسبه لكريشنار
اوغلو خلال المرحله المقبله من اسطنبول
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي طه عوده شكرا
جزيلا لك
في فصل الاخر من فصول التصعيد بين بكين
وواشنطن انتقد المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه وانجون بن الخطه
الامريكيه المتعلقه بتدمير بمصانع الرقائق
في تايوان اذا اقدمت بكين على ضم الجزيره
متابعه
اذا كنت اتذكر بشكل صحيح فقد ادعى هذا
المسؤول الكبير السابق من البيت الابيض
مؤخرا ان الولايات المتحده تفضل تدمير
مصانع اشباه الموصلات في تايوان بدلا من
تركها والحقيقه ان السلطات التايوانيه
منحت ميداليات لهؤلاء المدافعين عن خطه
تدمير تايوان وهذا يظهر ان حبهم المعلن
لتايوان مزيف وان بيع تايوان هو النيه
الحقيقيه
الصراع بين واشنطن مشاهدينا وبكين يمتد
الى تيك توك هو بكل تاكيد واستمخاوف
لاساءه استخدام بيانات المستخدمين من قبل
المسؤولين الصينيين قد يفقد التطبيق
مستخدميه يقدر عددهم ب 150 مليون شخص داخل
الولايات المتحده وسط دعوات متزايده لحظر
التطبيق لاسباب تتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي يامل شوتشي وهو الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه يامل في تهدئه المخاوف الامريكيه
في شهاده مرتقبه غدا امام لجنه الطاقه
والتجاره بمجلس النواب الامريكي والتي
استبقها بالتاكيد على ان التطبيق المملوك
للصينيين لم ولي يشارك بيانات مستخدميه
الامريكيين مع الحكومه الصينيه اذا ما
فشلت شيتشو في اقناع الكونجرس سيكون امامه
خيارين كلاهما او خياران كلاهما سيء اما
الحظر او الاجبار على البيع القصري طبعا
وفقا لشهاده مكتوبه نشرت مسبقا سيقول تشيت
شو امام الكونجرس ان تيك توك لم يشارك
مطلقا
يتلقى طلبا لمشاركه بيانات المستخدمين مع
الحكومه الصينيه
ولن يولي مثل هذا الطلب اهتمام اذا تلقاه
وطبعا في اي وقت من الاوقات يتخوف منتقده
تيك توك من امكان تسريب بيانات المستخدمين
الى الحكومه الصينيه اطلقوا ايضا دعوات
متزايده للمشرعين الامريكيين لحظره ولم
تقف الحكومه الصينيه متفرجه حيث دخلت على
الخط دعت واشنطن لتوقفي عن قمع الشركات
الاجنبيه مؤكده ان واشنطن لم تقدم ادله
على ان تيك توك يهدد الامن القومي
في ظل المخاوف المستمره من تطبيق تيك توك
وامكانيه حظره بشكل تام انضمت النرويج الى
قائمه الدول التي حضرت استخدام التطبيق
على هواتف موظفه الرسميين لتلحق بالولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في الخطوه ذاتها
انكار مستمر من قبل الشركه حول المخاوف
المتداوله على الامن القومي الامريكي
فالرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك اكد ان التطبيق
لم ولن يشارك بيانات مستخدمه الامريكيين
مع الحكومه الصينيه وينتظر ان يدلي شوتشي
تشو بشهادته امام لجنه الطاقه والتجاره
بمجلس النواب الامريكي
شركه باي دانس ليست مملوكه لاي كيان حكومي
او تخضع لسيطرته وليست عميله للصين او لاي
دوله اخرى
مظله الدول التي تتوجس مما يمكن ان يفعله
تيك توك تتسع لتصل الى حظر المنصه بشكل
تام في الكثير من الدول
وفق الحكومات وشركات الامن السيبراني فان
تيك توك قادر على الوصول الى البيانات
وجهه الاتصال والموقع الجغرافي وشبكات
الانترنت وبطاقه السم ايضا والخوف الاكبر
هو تسليم تلك المعلومات الى الحكومه
الصينيه من قبل شركه بايت دانس الملكه
للتطبيق رغم ان تيك توك يؤكد على ان
البيانات مخزنه خارج الصين وبالتحديد في
سنغافوره وامريكا مؤكدا انه لن يستجيب لاي
طلب حكوميا صيني بالحصول على المعلومات في
حال تقديمه الا ان ذلك لم يهدئ من روع
المنتقدين خاصه ان مقر الشركه الام هو في
الصين وعمر العربيه
وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه
شكرا متابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]